[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show my guest
today one of my favorites one of your
favorites aj jacobs aj jacobs is a
best-selling author journalist and human
guinea pig now
all of you long-term listeners know i do
not apply that term that label lightly
but in this case it applies he has
written four narratives bestsellers
including one of my favorites the year
of living biblically for which he
followed all of the rules of the bible
as literally as possible including i
should mention stoning adulterers you'll
have to read it to get that and thanks a
thousand for which he went around the
world and thanked every person who had
even the smallest role in making his
morning cup of coffee possible i thought
about this morning as i had my coffee he
has given four ted talks with the
combined 10 million plus views he
contributes to npr in the new york times
and wrote the article my outsourced life
which was featured in the four hour work
week
what a title for our work week who wrote
that sounds like an infomercial he was
once the answer to one down in the new
york times crossword puzzle you can find
my 2016 good lord that's a long time ago
interview with aj where we cover a lot
of backstory a lot of
our
shared converging paths in life at
tim.blog
aj you can find them online ajacobs.com
the website for the new book is
thepuzzlerbook.com
and we'll link to all the social as well
but it tends to be aj jacobs on twitter
facebook etc
and aj it is so lovely to see you again
i am so delighted to be back and first i
have to
say thank you
because for many things but one is that
beloved entertainer hugh jackman
read my book on gratitude because of you
you know he's a huge listener and he put
it on instagram and that was the first
time in my life that my kids showed a
modicum of respect to me because
wolverine
said that my book was okay oh it's
amazing i'm indebted thank you
uh you're most welcome
hugh is a sweet guy and that was thanks
a thousand or which which book was it
you added it was thanks and he's also
into coffee he has a coffee company so
it all worked together
the colliding worlds collide yet again
as as the world gets smaller and smaller
it seems every day aj tim you are
prolific
and
i wanted to start
with a bit of a flashback and then we'll
come to presents so
i have
read this is on 80 000. org and we may
have covered quite a bit of this in our
first conversation because we did
discuss creative process and writing
process which i'm sure we'll touch on
here again
that at least with some of your books
you've had a spreadsheet
and you send the manuscript out to say
20 friends who are nice enough to read
it and you'll ask each of them to tell
you their five favorite parts five least
favorite parts and then you sort of look
for patterns to make decisions on what
to cut or keep and i'm curious to know
what
you can answer this in either order but
what got cut from the puzzler that you
really hoped would make it and then what
ended up being a fan favorite a
proofreader favorite well i love that i
might well have gotten that strategy
from you
i can't do something very similar yes i
do something very similar so thank you
i'm giving you full credit now
but uh well the weird thing is that
strategy usually does work with this
book it was a complete failure because
everyone has their own favorite type of
puzzle and i cover 20 different types of
puzzles so they're people who love
crosswords sudoku's jigsaws
logic secret codes and everyone was like
this is the best chapter and this one
sucks and they were all over the map
there was no way to see the signal in
the noise and it was a it was a huge
flop
so it didn't help at all spreadsheet
fail spreadsheet fail all right so now
just for people who don't have any
contacts the puzzler subtitle you are i
i also don't
i mean bestow sounds a little grandiose
use this i wouldn't say this lightly and
that is you are a master of subtitles
oh well they're long subtitles are
important well yes they are long maybe i
think that's that's part of the affinity
i like long subtitles too one man's
quest to solve the most baffling puzzles
ever from crosswords crosswords i got a
little elmer fudd from crosswords to
jigsaws to the meaning of life so
there's a lot to unpack there
what made the short list of next books
possible next books for you and how did
you settle on
the puzzler
well it's interesting i actually worked
on another book for three months
and abandon it right in the middle
because i was miserable
and one of the big themes of the puzzler
is you got to be flexible you got to
pivot you got to
always be
open to new ideas and this was an
example of it i still think it's an
interesting idea the idea was
about it was
called tentatively fact checking my life
and it was about the post-truth crisis
so
what do we know and how do we know it
how do i know that the world is round
how do i know that my wife loves me she
says she loves me i don't know how do i
know anything and i was working on it
and i was just miserable because i felt
i didn't i didn't know anything and it
was freaking me out so
i may come back to it but
my agent
said you know you love puzzles he knows
that that's my obsession and he said why
don't you just do a book about your true
passion and i thought it was fascinating
because in a sense
i have loved puzzles since i was a kid
and all of my books are about
metaphorical puzzles like the year of
living biblically was about
the puzzle of religion the gratitude
book was how do you be more grateful in
this world where it's sometimes very
difficult to be grateful and this was
like all right i'm going to stop beating
around the bush i'm going to focus on
literal puzzles and why do i love them
why do millions love them what can they
teach us and how can they make us better
thinkers and so i went all in for two
years just a deep dive and i got to do
meet crazy people and do puzzles as my
job so i was super grateful
you've been described as the george
plimpton of of thought experiments which
i think is is pretty apt and for people
who don't know george plympton worth
checking him out but he would
i think he did a few rounds with sunny
liston which uh if you don't know that
name you can look it up but suffice to
say punches a lot harder than george
plimpton professional boxer and then
would write about the experience or
become a professional football player
for a period of time and write about the
experience
i wouldn't say that what you do is
purely mental but it sounds almost like
what you attempted with the
fact-checking book
was similar to someone else
you have quite a bit of respect from
blanking on her name but a female writer
who did quite a lot of let's call it
immersive journalism one
experiment of which was
admitting herself to a mental hospital
to show the abuses therein oh right this
was the
from the 1800s like not occurring in the
1800s no this is not current right and i
was just thinking i was thinking as as i
did a little bit of research and she
popped up
you having mentioned her once before
that
getting admitted is the easy part
you know how do you especially as a
woman in the 1800s get yourself out of a
situation like that
but then if you're the one sort of
imposing insanity or
in the form of not
knowing what is true or what is not what
is
real or what is not when you're fact
checking your life i can see how that
would be very anxiety producing as as a
first attempt yeah
i have two comments first of all thank
you for saying
i'm the george clinton uh it was written
somewhere i prefer to might
think of myself as the less successful
tim ferriss
because you are the master
of life experiments and
i'm just trying to keep up with you i
just go for the cheap applause with fat
loss and writing about sex and nfts and
so on so
you're taking more honorable paths i
don't know
less successful but honorable
and yes that woman you mentioned was
nellie bly and she was a great character
i don't know there should be a movie
about her when the book around the world
in 80 days she actually did it she's
like all right i'm gonna do it so she
was sort of the original guinea pig and
she also did a very tim ferriss
experiment i think where
she
decided to write an article
about and this might be a little
apocryphal but i think it's true about
why they're not more women in journalism
and she interviewed
she got an interview with all of the
editors in chief of all the major
newspapers in new york and that's how
she made the connection and they're like
oh yeah maybe we should hire so that's
how she got her job and i just think
it's like you know that to me is sort of
how you
came out of being a first-time writer
and four-hour work week like mega
blockbuster you like met people
you know you approached me i didn't do
much for you but other people did
well i i would refute that that you
didn't do much for me hey you're very
generous with your time and i think were
you working on the year of living
biblically at the time you might have
been so i caught you
in a period where
i think you were
trying very hard to be compassionate
you're already a nice guy but i may have
caught you in a really good window
yes but you were
very helpful and you gave me a lot of
great advice when i was writing i
remember the coffee shop in buenos aires
where i was and whenever it was 2005
2006
when we were chatting it must have been
via skype or something at the time so
i owe you thanks for that my pleasure
so puzzles i have
i don't want to say abandoned but i was
i was when young
a fan of all sorts of puzzles and i
think as i got older somehow convinced
myself that i shouldn't spend time on
certain frivolous activities after
college anyway and have let certain
muscles atrophy perhaps you could just
give us a little context and you can
tackle it any way you want as to why
puzzles are
important or meaningful
or valuable and you could do that via
telling a story giving us some
historical context any any way you'd
like to tackle that
i think that puzzles are the opposite of
frivolous
and i hope that i can entice you to come
back first of all you do
even though you say you don't do puzzles
you do puzzles because you're one of the
most curious guys i've ever met and
innovative thinkers and that is the
essence of puzzles it's a problem where
you use curiosity and innovative
thinking to solve it so you do you do
puzzles even if you don't think so and
these little puzzles like crosswords and
and logic of secret codes they're just
ways to help you come up with strategies
to solve the big problems in life so
little puzzles help you with the big
puzzles
i've always loved puzzles and i never
i never lost
my obsession about five years ago as you
mentioned in your intro i was the answer
to a clue in the new york times
crossword puzzle one down author aj
blank and as a word nerd i was like this
is the greatest moment in my life this
is better than my kids being born my
marriage
and then my brother-in-law pointed out
correctly if a little ungenerously that
i appeared in the saturday new york
times cross refers and if you know
anything about crosswords in the new
york times saturday is where is the
hardest harder than sunday all the
answers are totally obscure no one knows
them so his point was this is not a
compliment like you are just this is
proof you're totally obscure no one
knows who you are so i told that story
on a podcast and it happened that a new
york times crossword constructor was
listening and saved me and put me in a
tuesday puzzle which i don't belong in
that's where like you might belong where
lady gaga but not me so i didn't belong
but i loved it and that
that reignited i
i had done a little less obsession i was
like oh man so i started doing the
crossword every day hoping to reappear
after that saturday
but i'm not monogamous i'm promiscuous i
love all kinds of puzzles except i did
not love jigsaws which we can get into
until this until this project and now i
have tremendous respect for jigsaws
which is all about flexible thinking as
we mentioned being okay with being wrong
how does one compete
in
the world jigsaw puzzle championships so
this i believe was in spain
what does such a competition
look like because i i can imagine that
many people cannot imagine including
myself what that looks like this is true
for a lot of competitions right there
are memory competitions and there are
different events it's kind of like a
decathlon of
of attentional
focus and so on but what is what is a
jigsaw puzzle championship look like i
was totally surprised because i always
think of it as a relaxing meditative so
it's like
you know a meditation competition or or
a napping
uh competition but i found out about it
because i was googling first of all one
of the first facts about jigsaws is that
hugh jackman is a huge fan huge he spent
about 10 minutes of maybe 15
on
our podcast he and i together talking
about jigsaw puzzles so yes huge jigsaw
puzzle fan but one of the other results
this is right before the pandemic was
that there was a
world championship in spain and it
listed all of the countries that were
competing and there were tons of them
there were 40 countries mexico japan
uganda but no usa so on a whim i fill
out the form and figure that'll be the
first of this long process to qualify i
get back an email the next day you are
team usa and i'm like oh why that's not
good the next day no due diligence at
all
it was a disaster uh yeah and i as i
said i didn't love jake's i thought they
were i was a snob i thought they were
too easy they were not sophisticated so
i was like oh god so i recruited my
family to be as a four-person team and
we flew to spain and
you have eight hours
to finish four giant jigsaw puzzles and
we were a disas i mean i'm sorry i
apologize to my fellow americans because
we came in second to last we be we beat
one of the spanish hometown teams so
that's something but these
despite us the humiliation i loved it
because it was just so fascinating for
so many reasons first just being able to
see people at the top of
the lebron james's of jigsaw so no even
if jigsaw is you think is a silly
as a silly past i'm seeing anyone and
you know this you've interviewed that's
sort of the premise you interview the
top people of every category and you're
going to learn something from them and
these people their hands move so fast
we
finished one puzzle
of the four in six and a half hours
the russian team these women four women
from siberia finished in
just over four hours the whole thing
they their hands were moving so fast and
there were rumors of doping but i'm not
to not confirm um
and the another part i loved was just
meeting people from all over the world
united by this weird obsession and i
talk about jigsaw diplomacy i actually i
felt i was a little ahead of the curve
because i have a paragraph in the book
about how much i hate putin
this was long before the ukraine before
it was cool yeah
before it was going and i say but i
can't hate these people because i'm here
in face to face and they're humans and
you know i am hoping that they're one of
the some of the millions who oppose what
putin is doing now but
but it was sort of like what i call
jigsaw diplomacy
so it was a wonderful experience and
also learning
like in everything there are strategies
you think oh it's just putting together
but and the strategies are sometimes
surprising you don't always everyone's
like oh do the do the edges first no not
necessarily some puzzles if they have
very colorful you do the colors first
sometimes you focus on shapes if you're
hit with the sky like a huge expanse of
blue you've got to sort them by shapes
so this one has two audis and one innie
this one so
it was just wonderful to see the nuances
of
this
delightful and ridiculous competition
and yeah it was one of my favorite
experiences i have a number of questions
about this the first is
how do you
delegate
or divide and conquer as a team because
i can imagine
if four people were just let loose
having no strategy trying to put
together a jigsaw puzzle it might take
longer than just one person trying to do
it if you don't have some type of plan
going into it and second i'm just
curious did you notice any sponsors i'm
just wondering what kind of
financial support is offered to the
world jigsaw
puzzle championships
i'm guessing it's not you know bmw maybe
not yet but i mean this was right before
the covet when jigsaws experienced a
boom during coven that's true not seen
since the great depression so they
became harder to get than clorox wipes
so so maybe now
they could be sponsored by vmware but
then yes it was
the only sponsor was the puzzle company
itself ravensburger sadly so i didn't
make a huge amount of money on it as the
second to last finisher
so for strategies like yeah what do you
do as a team well you're absolutely
right that was the secret that the
russians had they told me it's all about
division of labor like in many endeavors
so there was one woman who specialized
in sorting colors and another assorted
shapes another sorted what was good at
the edges and another was really good at
the trial and error
because you i often am you know i'm
afraid to put something down if i don't
think she was like no just do it just be
okay with failing you know she put
things she'd try it no next one no next
one yes
so
yeah it was fascinating to see the
division and i found that as a theme
throughout puzzle solving i went to this
one event that was sort of the iron man
triathlon for nerds which was called a
puzzle hunt and it was at mit 2000
people like rock real rocket scientists
and they come together for 72 hours and
solve the hardest
craziest most baffling nonsensical
puzzles that involve like
advanced calculus and justin bieber's
tour schedule and just the most random
things you can think of and you need 50
people on a team the teams are 50 people
because you needed specialists
and all these areas so yes
sort of a diversification and uh having
different people do different things is
a big theme
i think in in puzzles and life
i'll mention i i do have a number of
friends or if i've known people through
my life who have been
i don't think obsessed is is an
overstatement obsessed with puzzles of
different types and i was i wanted to
get the attribution right one of them
was one of the most curious and
intelligent
people i've ever met
john horton conway and i'm looking at
his wikipedia unfortunately he passed
away some time ago but english
mathematician active in the theory of
finite groups not theory number theory
combinatorial game theory and coding
theory uh he was
in cambridge and then moved to the u.s
and held john von neumann i'm guessing
that's how that's pronounced
professorship at princeton university
and he could recite pie to several
thousand digits and he would do it
musically i think he and his partner
did that together as they would go for
walks and
he was so what struck me about him i'm
not saying
that the puzzles are entirely causal
here right there's a lot going into this
but
he was very
childlike in
two respects a his enthusiasm for
any type of puzzle they could be
mathematical could be societal it could
be a physical game he had physical games
all over his office
and he was also very very good at
explaining complex concepts
simply and i remember for a period of
time he did public lectures on
mathematics and they were standing room
only and people would come from all over
the place from all different walks of
life
so
that is to say my my connotation
with puzzles also is very positive even
though i have let my muscles maybe
atrophy when working with what we would
consider formal games like jigsaw
puzzles and so on
you know the connotation is really
positive
and i'm i'm wondering
what you have observed over the process
of working on this book writing this
book engaging with all the puzzles about
your own
thought processes or how
the
working on the small puzzles has helped
with other types of puzzles
well first of all he sounds great i'm
sorry he's not around i would have
interviewed him yeah
and i agree
what you characterize is the the
enthusiasm and curiosity
i love that to me the two of the big
themes of this book in terms of thought
processes are our curiosity and flexible
thinking and i i love curio you know
you're one of the most curious people i
think it's one of the greatest drives or
that humans have along with gratitude
gratitude and curiosity to me are
two amazing
forces and actually i interviewed alex
trebek the late great alex trebek
from jeopardy once and he said a quote
that i still think about all the time
even though it doesn't quite make sense
it still totally makes sense to me and
that quote is
i'm curious about everything even those
things that don't interest me
so he's curious about everything even
those even the most boring things and i
love that because i think it's true
whatever the topic is you are going to
if you dig a little you're going to find
fascinating and and in fact i once
thought of
a dude trying like a challenge where i
write a book about the most
stereotypically boring thing in the
world maybe it's accounting and
trying to make it interesting because it
i'm sure it is it's not about numbers
it's about people it's about actions and
business and love and hate so anyway
curiosity i think puzzles just fuel my
curiosity and as i said i see the world
as a puzzle i have what i like to call
the puzzle mindset which is i think so
important when you are looking at world
problems to adopt the puzzle mindset
which is opposed to sort of the
motivated reasoning or or anger mindset
there's a child psychologist i saw who
said don't get furious get curious
as
parenting advice but i think that's
great life advice
because
that really is if you're going to solve
a problem curiosity is the way to do it
not anger anger gives you tunnel vision
like if i'm talking to someone from the
opposite side of the political spectrum
instead of seeing it as a debate a war
of words i try to see it as a puzzle
that we can try to solve together
what what do we really
believe
what is our real differences and how can
we overcome them are is there any
evidence i can present to him or her to
make her change her mind what is how do
we solve this puzzle
so anyway that to me is sort of the big
thesis thrust of the book don't get
furious well get a little furious
sometimes you need to but balance it
with curiosity
i would imagine you still
outline your books quite a bit you sort
of think about the structure in advance
were there any particular
twists or turns or surprises or things
that you found surprising
in the process of
putting this book together
structure to me is everything and i have
to structure like my book on health
which was sort of the
the much less selling for our body
version and i structured it by body
parts so you know a part on stomach
health and what you eat and lung health
how you work out but even hand health
and butt health like you know how you go
to the bathroom and i will say i missed
a huge opportunity which i realized
during this i didn't have an appendix i
should have had an appendix about a
pennant what was i thinking but anyway
yes so many surprises and
and i think that for me writing is a
combination of
knowing where i'm going i do structure
it and outline it very thoroughly but
also allowing for some surprises and
twists and turns like for instance i
have a chapter on this crazy unsolved
puzzle which is located at the
headquarters of the cia and i
got permission after months to visit the
cia and see this puzzle in person
and i decided afterwards like how should
i write this and i decide i'm going to
write it like like a thriller like a spy
thriller so that chapter almost i tried
to make it read like a spy thriller and
that was not planned but it is a
fascinating and we can talk about it
it's called kryptos one of the craziest
puzzles known why is there a puzzle at
the
cia
so yes let's talk about it what is this
and why is it housed at the cia it's one
of my favorite chapters because yeah it
was commissioned 32 years ago by the cia
they wanted to spruce up their grounds
and this guy a sculptor teamed with an
xcia cryptographer and they made the
sculpture which is basically a huge
metal
wall with thousands of letters on it and
the letters are a secret code and they
thought it would be solved in like a
week it's been 32 years and
no one including the cia which is right
there has been able to solve it
fully they have solved parts of it and
part of it seems to indicate that
there's something buried on the grounds
of the cia and we don't know what it is
it could be treasure it could be the
poison cigar we gave castro who knows
but what i love about it is many things
but one thing i love about it is that
there's a group of thousands of people
i'm on the online group that spend their
days hours a day trying to crack this
code and 32 years they've been working
at it so that to me is like the true
puzzle mindset of grit like they are
when i help my kids with math homework
and i give up after like three minutes i
just i now have to say these these folks
have been working for 32 years on this
problem i'm going to give it another
couple of minutes so yeah kryptos is a
fantastic puzzle and i will say just one
addendum the the sculptor is not just a
genius
coder and sculptor he's also a great
businessman and i think you'll
appreciate this he got sick and tired
because he'd get dozens of emails every
day saying is the answer to this is the
answer to that so he decided i will
answer you yes or no but you have to pay
me fifty dollars you have to pay
penalties genius these makes who knows
how much hundreds of dollars a day just
starting nope that's not right that is
genius i'm wondering if this sculptor is
also just the most epic troll of all
time in the sense that he just created a
nonsensical
that is such a great point and i will
tell you a piece of work that cannot be
broken because there is no message in
which case he's just created this
amazing annuity stream for himself
that's lasted 32 years can you imagine
it is possible that those people aren't
and i will say there is
historical precedent for that there's
the most famous puzzler of the 1900s was
this guy he's like the will shorts of
his day you know the new york times will
short and he
he sold millions of this puzzle called
the 15 puzzle which you've probably seen
as a kid it's the little tiles he moved
the tiles around they numbered one
through 15 and you have to make them in
a square that
and he had a contest where he would give
i believe it was
ten thousand dollars at the time which
was huge
that if someone solved this particular
arrangement they would win the money
but what he didn't tell him is that
half of the initial arrangements are
impossible to solve just mathematically
impossible to solve and he put it in one
of those so he was like a super troller
from that era and i will say just i have
a contest there's a secret hidden code
in the book and if you put it into the
website you can do these puzzles and try
to win ten thousand dollars
they have
i am not a troll they have an actual
answer so there is a real contest
and uh and i think actually since you
are first out of the gate i think you
might be the first time i've mentioned
it fantastic well there you have it
folks
and this this brings up sort of a
a more
meta
commentary on the book which is not just
about puzzles it includes
quite a lot of puzzles so you mentioned
the sculptor you mentioned this this
puzzler and the 15
what makes a puzzler if you were doing
let's just say like a cia profile
looking for patterns across the puzzlers
like what makes a good puzzler because
you were helped in this book by master
puzzle maker greg pliska am i saying
that name correctly yes yes there are
hundreds of historical puzzles but also
a bunch of new puzzles by greg who's
amazing and i would say i actually tried
to make some puzzles my wife has a
company watson adventures that puts on
scavenger hunts and she hired me
by not paying me to make a bunch of
puzzles and i think they're okay the
puzzles but i am not i don't have it in
me because you do need a certain level
of sadism you need to be okay with
putting people through the pain because
that's what people want they want to
experience pain and then the release
from pain they want that dopamine hit
and i don't know if you've had him on
the podcast paul bloom great writer he
wrote a book about why do we as humans
why do we want to do these painful why
do we run marathons why do we do puzzles
why why s m and and it is a lot about
this idea of
we are programmed to struggle struggle
struggle and then get that payoff you
have to struggle to get that dopamine
hit but you have to be a little sadistic
to be a great puzzler and i i didn't
have it in me so i i stick with the
masochism of doing puzzles
what other
attributes do you spot whether those are
innate
nature
god-given attributes or
developed skills in people who are good
at creating puzzles i or is it just
sheer volume of exposure these have to
be people who have digested and seen a
million varieties of puzzles
how would you describe just as a
category or greg specifically
what makes what are the ingredients that
make a good puzzler
well i do believe anyone can be a good
puzzler if you can tolerate the sadism
puzzle maker but i would say yeah the
the idea for curiosity an innovative
thing i mean
puzzles
the best puzzles are the ones that are
just make you go
oh my god why didn't i see that yeah and
it's something in your mind you feel you
should have known and you're like oh
that is so clever
as opposed to
crappy puzzles where you're like oh that
wasn't fair
or they're just boring like an escape
room where you have 100 keys and you
have to try every key in the lock that's
just that's just busy work that's just
like doing the dishes
the key is the leap that leap of
ingenuity
you know the the cliche is outside the
box think outside the box which actually
comes from a puzzle that's where it
originates the puzzle has three nine
dots three on each row and you have to
draw yeah this is a good one yeah you
have to draw
four lines that's right and connect all
the dots and the only way to do it is to
go you've drawn the lines so far outside
the box that the diagonals line up oh
wow i didn't realize that's the origin
of that expression that's cool i did not
i did not know that yeah i think outside
and i do believe that's what the great
you know mrna vaccine was thinking
outside the box like make just part of
the virus so that it kicks in the immune
system don't don't make the whole virus
i mean that was a leap that was a
brilliant way to uh to approach it
so what are some
techniques
mental strategies
anything that we can borrow from
solving puzzles making puzzles either
and apply in other areas
i got some i got some for you i thought
you might i have four or five
that i thought we could go through at
that
to me illuminate some of the best
strategies so let me start with a little
puzzle okay and we'll work through it
together i'm not gonna because i am very
bad at doing puzzles on the spot and the
stress so i don't want to put you
you know i know you're brilliant so we
all know that cultivate your inner
sadist
maybe it'll make you a better puzzle
maker
so this is a
puzzle that's based on a famous story of
a german mathematician named gauss in
the 1700s and he was nine years old in
school and the teacher said
the assignment is add up all of the
whole numbers from one to a hundred
and tell me the answer and two seconds
later gauss raises his hand and the
teacher's like what the hell you
couldn't have done it the cow says no i
i did it so so the puzzle is how did he
do it how did he add up
one through a hundred oh boy
i'm gonna just tuffy go stuffy yeah yeah
let's skip straight no chaser
i'll leave it to you
get to the spoiler
i mean the default way which is what i
thought and most people think you add
one plus two is three you know one plus
two plus three three plus three is six
and you just go straight through
but gauss realized
now that there's a better method
because one plus a hundred is one
hundred one two plus ninety-nine is a
hundred one three plus ninety-eight is a
hundred one so you take these pairs and
they're fifty pairs so fifty times a
hundred one that's not that hard five
thousand fifty that's the answer so to
me
this is a very tim ferriss way to think
because what he what he did was he
didn't immediately just dive into
solving the problem and doing the busy
work he took a step back and he said
what is the meta strategy what am i
actually what's my goal what is a better
way to solve this problem
and you know many of your books like
have a lot of this the four-hour work
week is what is the real goal is the
goal to have as many clients as possible
or is it to have a good life and make
enough money so fire those
pain-in-the-ass clients to me that is a
very gaussian way to approach it
wow how old would nine years old
you know who knows what it is but yeah
yeah for sure but it makes it makes for
a good story is this the am i making
this up is this the gauss of
gaussian distribution i wonder i'm
thinking
yeah the gaussian distribution which is
a normal distribution i won't take us
too far down
down that rabbit hole
all right so so
gauss
nine-year-old one tim ferris zero but i
appreciate the approach it is very
abraham lincoln too and of course
probably apocryphal maybe it's
attributed to groucho marx or uh
gandhi online because those tend to be
three of the top sort of blanket
attributions but if i have four hours to
chop down a tree i'd spend the first
three hours sharpening the axe so
thinking about the meta strategy and the
right tool for the job yeah that's the
good thing all right can i give you
another uh oh
god damn it aj you're always
interrupting me on this podcast when i'm
supposed to be asking you questions
please continue yes number two all right
another strategy that i love is we
talked about it before just the
flexibility just the flexibility of mind
is so crucial getting caught in a mental
rut is the enemy of coming up with good
solutions and i'll give you
a puzzle example and then a real life
example so the puzzle example is i have
a section on british crosswords which
are
insane crazy much harder than americans
they have all these weird
obscure
word plays and you don't know what's
going on so
for instance one of the clues in the
british crossword was the letters four
letters
g-e-g-s g-e-g-s and i'm like all right
what is a gag so i focus what is a gag
and i look it up i even use google which
i try not to do and it's the portland
symbol for the portland airport is a gag
and there are a couple other like urban
dictionary gags that maybe are not
appropriate so anyway i'm like focus
what is a gig and i finally just give up
after half an hour and take a break i
don't give up i take a break which is
also
a huge puzzle and problem solving
strategy take a break because it resets
your mind leonardo da vinci talked about
taking breaks
so i took a break and i came back and i
was like maybe it's not a gig maybe
there's something in the
in the letters and and eventually i
noticed that that gags
if you rearrange them
is eggs e-g-g-s
so the answer is scrambled eggs gags is
scrambled eggs
so
which was annoying but also brilliant
yeah but that to me is the key don't
lock in on your thesis have it
provisional always be open to new ways
of looking at it jigsaws is an example i
hated jigsaws and i i found that they
are incredibly subtle and interesting or
um or i was obsessed with ending this
puzzle book in a certain way and i was
talking to my son and and i'm like and
he's like i don't know that doesn't
sound great so i totally abandoned that
so yeah flexible thinking loosely held
belief i am a big fan of some beliefs
you should hold deeply like you know
don't be an [ __ ] that belief to me is
like you know that's sacrosanct but many
other beliefs i have are just
provisional probabilistic
why are jigsaw puzzles called jigsaw
puzzles is the jigsaw a tool they used
to cut the pieces well originally yes
yes it was they made them out of wood
and they used a jigsaw which is a saw
i think it's sort of in the shape of a
question mark with a saw and you you
carve it and there still are hand carved
wooden puzzles there's one of the
chapters i go to
this crazy
company in vermont that makes
hand carved wooden puzzles that are
insanely expensive like go they go up to
ten thousand dollars oh they must bill
gates is a fan the guy who owns it calls
himself the chief tormentor because
they're not regular puzzles he is
sadistic he loves to see them
so yeah because they're totally
different than normal puzzles they they
have holes in them they have pieces that
don't fit oh wow they have pieces that
go three-dimensional so yeah i am a big
fan that's called steve puzzles so if
you have enough money check it out
chief torturer
keep tormentor chief dweller
mentor pretty close pretty close to her
mentor i mean tormentor is like what
what the older sibling does to a younger
sibling is a little less intense than
torture but nonetheless
all right so
another yeah another please all right
well this one i love the idea is to
reverse your thinking to think upside
down to think totally differently so
i'll give you a riddle a classic riddle
there's a man in a room
the walls are cement and the floor is
dirt and the only opening is this locked
door in the room and a skylight
the man has a shovel
and he starts to dig he knows it's
impossible to tunnel out but he
continues to dig anyway
so what's going on why is he keep
digging even though he knows he can't
tunnel out
so this one i'm going to admit i i know
the answer to so i don't want to i don't
want to do too much you know thanking of
the academy for my acting as i pretend
like i don't know the answer but why
don't why don't you explain it and
and then i'll i'll have a little bit of
commentary because i i love these types
of riddles and when i was younger i
actually did and by younger i mean even
up through high school
and maybe even early college love these
types of riddles that force you to
check a lot of your assumptions about
whatever you just heard so why don't you
unpack that please
well
i'm very impressed with your honesty
it's actually just a quick side note
i have a chapter on escape rooms and the
escape room owners tell me that there's
always
a guy who comes every week with a date a
new woman and pretends that it's his
first time at the escape room
and she's supposed to be like wow you
can solve the nato alphabet i want to go
to bed with you
i guess that's the theory but anyway
so it's quite a racket there guys
running
dozens of guys across the country they
all say they have one
so the idea the way to do this is to
reverse your thinking so instead of
focusing on the fact that he's digging
whole what what else is he doing he's
doing the opposite he's building a
mountain a little mountain of dirt and
he's going to climb that mountain and
get to the skylight and i love this
because i use it in everyday life i use
it you know collecting the laundry i i
reverse my thinking
and this one came up yesterday hold on
hold on
collecting the laundry how do you apply
please explain i live with three teenage
boys so there are clothes
every corner uh so i used to go around
and collect them an arm load and put
them in the hamper in our bedroom but i
realized
what if i took the hamper with me
and
and put the clothes in so i don't have
to make as many trips so i like reversed
it i was like bring the hamper to the
clothes so yes i am a genius that is the
conclusion
but to give you another example that's
maybe more i don't know
important
my son said to me
yesterday if the power goes out what's
to stop the elevator from plummeting to
the basement and killing us and i looked
it up and it turns out
that elevator brakes work the opposite
of the way you think the default is that
the elevator brakes are clamped on the
elevator and they only are released when
there's an electric current so the
electromagnetism opens them up so if the
electricity goes out if there's a
blackout the brakes automatically clamp
on which is the opposite of what i would
have thought you need to activate the
brakes but some genius said no this this
is a better system so uh whoever it is
thank you for that for uh i'm sure
you've saved my
life i love these word riddles
and you know i actually you know one
came to mind i'm not gonna get it
totally right but this is from like 20
years ago 25 years ago they could be so
simple
there's a woman who's afraid she's
afraid because
she can't go home because the man with
the mask is there
who is the man in the mask right and
then the
person who's attempting to answer it can
ask yes or no questions this is sort of
a common game that we would play and you
can think about it you can go through
all sorts of hoops and ultimately in
this example it's a game of baseball
right i like to go to home base yeah
okay sometimes i've heard it as two men
in masks because you've got the uh right
yeah that'd be a better way of phrasing
it for sure
what are these types i mean are they
just known as riddles or are these those
are sometimes called lateral thinking
and again the idea is lateral thinking
involves totally reframing and
looking at what your assumptions are
which again i think is crucial in
thinking about real life problems and
yeah a very ferrous so i'm surprised
that you even gave them up because they
are very fairest ways of thinking
they're super fun i think i think i was
just
encountering them piecemeal and didn't
know where to find a
collection of them i think that's
probably what it came down to is that i
would very
once in a blue moon run into something i
remember another one which was and you
probably know the better phrasing but it
was something like
there's a man in a room he's dead on the
floor
and there are 53 bicycles in the room
what happened
and
he was cheating at cards
right right yeah the bicycle cards and i
love that
but it takes a while well i can send you
a website with all of them i don't have
it often or you can buy my book which
has
get the book folks it's painless
that's you got to be shameless sometimes
especially on podcasts
that's right
if you were choosing
for yourself kind of best bang for the
buck puzzles and by bang for the buck i
mean
puzzles that are enjoyable slash
interesting enough that you'll keep
doing them but that also seem to have an
impact on the rest of your life and that
can be super broad right it could help
you sleep it could help you with your
thinking it could help in any way are
there any particular
types of puzzles
that
kind of make the final cut if you think
about them through that lens i love that
question well i guess i would break it
down into what is your goal so if your
goal again is to go to sleep then you
know jigsaws are very meditative if your
goal is to learn how to think then buy
one of these lateral thinking puzzles or
one of these incredibly hard
british puzzles british crosswords
also
one of my favorite genres that i knew
very little about is japanese puzzle
boxes so i would recommend that for
just for pure wonder and awe and these
are i actually went to japan where they
make them and they are wooden boxes but
they're works of art they're gorgeous
and you have they're they're locked and
you have to
manipulate them sometimes it's spinning
them sometimes it's turning them upside
down sometimes it's moving 100 slats in
in this certain order to open them
and and they have become this cult and
they're people who pay thousands of
dollars tens of thousands of dollars for
the most
you know rarest of these puzzle boxes
apparently russian oligarchs buy them up
or they used to i don't know if they can
afford it anymore hopefully not
these things are really extraordinary
and i will say i i'm friends with
you might know him john rulin who is uh
he's his expertise is
mythology he wrote giftology
it's all about
giving gifts and how they can make your
life better and make other people's
lives better so
they make these boxes in all sorts of
themes so i gave my editor
a japanese puzzle box in the shape of a
book
so if you are looking for a great gift
or you're looking for something to
inspire wonder and auth that's that's a
beautiful object that's a that's a good
one japanese puzzle boxes
you know i've i've actually seen some of
these in person in japan because as
you may or may not know lived there as
an exchange student for a year i've gone
back many times since
and they are stunningly beautiful
amazing and very intricate i mean you'll
have as you mentioned some you have to
turn upside down because there are
ball bearings or other
weight loaded components that will shift
only if you tilt them in a certain
direction uh absolutely stunning you
know it's yeah it's i was hoping to
bring this up because my latest book
i got is this which makes me think of a
lot about japan anyway not relevant to
the conversation the visions of japan by
kawasei hassui's
masterpieces a lot of people don't hocus
i would have been becoming more and more
interested in other
woodblock based artists and need to to
thank maria popova for that reference oh
yeah she's great and by the way have you
ever had darren aronofsky on the program
i have a long time ago long time ago
because he is super into puzzle boxes
and he actually designed one of the most
intricate i mean he commissioned one of
the most intricate puzzle boxes ever
it's a desk
by this artist named
kagan kagan sound and the desk is
has 22 secret puzzles in it and it took
kagan four years to make he lives in
colorado and it literally is like one of
darren's movies it drove him crazy like
he had a mental breakdown where's my
pencil oh no
so yeah they they are really remarkable
well let's talk about the the shadow
side of puzzles so it drove them crazy
yeah there is a there is a shadow sign i
see a bullet here tackling a logic
puzzle that literally drives people
insane and has spawned 100 philosophy
papers please tell me more about this
oh yes this is called the sleeping
beauty problem and it's a cousin of the
monty hall problem do you know the monty
hall i don't i don't know that either
maybe you could maybe you could explain
so the monty hall problem is a very
famous puzzle very controversial
and it was popularized by marilyn vos
savant i don't know if you've had her on
the show this woman who says she's got
the highest iq ever
so she wrote a column in parade magazine
no comment on why the smartest woman was
writing a braid magazine
column
because she's smarter than me so she
would slam me but anyway
the problem she popularized was this
suppose you're on a game show
and you're given a choice of three doors
behind one door is a car and behind the
other two doors are goats
assuming you want the car and not the
goats so your goal is to pick the door
with the car so you pick door number one
and the host he knows what's behind all
three doors and he says
well i'm gonna open door number three
before i answer whether you got it right
i'm opening door number three which and
behind that door is a goat then he says
to you
so you want to switch you want to pick
door number two instead
oh
my gut
and most people's gut is like no why why
would it matter it's like 50 50 right
but it's not oh
you should switch you should switch okay
so this is
this is a you know this is a better
question for my brother who has a lot of
statistics and mathematical
uh training and inclination okay so i
would not have no i would not have
passed i would have failed that test
most people do because it's so
counterintuitive and that's another big
theme of puzzles i think is that
don't trust your gut i am very wary of
my gut i feel my gut as an idiot
especially when it comes to
matters of probability so yes you should
switch and when she wrote this she got
hundreds of condescending letters from
from mathematicians saying you're an
idiot but she's right you should switch
and you can look it up why but basically
instead of your initial odds of one to
three you are choosing
you have a two out of three probability
of getting the car because he didn't
monty didn't just pick a random door he
knew what was behind all three doors and
he picked a goat so then it narrows it
down
but anyway this sleeping beauty problem
i mean i'm not i'm not gonna say it
because it's super complicated and it'll
put you to sleep but it is
it has it's in the book
but it has cause as you say a hundred
philosophy papers and i love it because
this is one of the puzzles that has no
correct people are still debating what
the answer is is the answer two out of
three or is it one out of two or
something else
so i love a puzzle that
that cannot be solved and actually as
part of the book i commissioned what i
believe is the hardest puzzle in the
history of the world and it cannot be
solved because you cannot solve it by
the time the universe runs out of energy
it's a mechanical puzzle where it's got
a metal rod inside a tower and in the
tower there are all these pegs and you
have to turn the pegs to remove the
the metal rod but you have to turn the
pegs many times many many times 1.2
decillion times which is one with 33
digits
yeah so it is literally if you do one
every second every nanosecond the
universe will will end and i love that i
love that
so what what was the impetus for
for creating this puzzle and this is
jacob's ladder am i right yes exactly
okay
a few reasons i loved it one
it's part of a genre called generation
puzzles where you pass them down from
generation to generation because no one
person can solve it so i love this idea
of connecting
generations and uh and thinking of you
mentioned 80 000 hours
and they talk a lot that's the effect of
altruism movement they talk a lot about
the far future and our our like you know
14th great grandkids and so this is sort
of a way to connect with that
one of the great japanese puzzle makers
he was called the godfather of sudoku
and he summarized puzzles and much of
life with three symbols the question
mark the forward arrow the exclamation
point you arrive you're baffled forward
hour arrow is the struggle the you know
the wrestling with the and then the
exclamation point is the revelation and
he said it's very zen he said you have
to embrace the arrow you have to learn
to love
the solving because you're not always
going to get to the exclamation point so
this is the ultimate arrow this arrow is
goes on until
you you know to the end of the universe
so i love that i love that and it's also
i love it because it's kind of like a
ritual that i can do a little meditative
ritual so yeah i am i am a big there's
only one in the world jacob's ladder
where is it located i'm looking at it
right now it's the left of my desk it's
taunting me
i mean the guy he's a brilliant puzzle
maker oscar van de venter was the one
who designed it so he's going to release
the plans on the internet so you can 3d
print one yourself so it will be
available
so it sounds like jacob's ladder
maybe the
if you commercialize this and sell it
the
company logo should be
the question mark and the forward arrow
without the exclamation point
i love it
all right
i'm in
well you are a collector of
experiments and experiences and
just if you look at your your
last handful of books then you certainly
span a lot of disciplines and what one
question i'm curious
to hear your answer to related to the
puzzler
is
what you think a year or two from now
you might still have
taken with you from this book whether
it's a habit a new type of puzzle could
be anything and i remember you and i
chatting years ago
after the year of living biblically and
one of the things that you took from
that for a period of time at least was
wearing white and then after that
wearing more colors
and
there's a lot more to that story but
what do you think you may take forth
from
all the work you've done on the puzzler
just to dip into the white
wearing white clothes i i love that that
at least at one point had an influence
on you because we you and i both are big
believers and the outer affects the
inner your behavior affects your
thoughts and so wearing white it just
has this connotation of lightness and
like you're going to go play wimbledon
or i think i used in the book that you
might go to p diddy's white party i
don't think exists anymore but anyway
yes that was one of the many things i
took away i also took away from that
gratitude which turned into its own book
for this one
the the puzzle mindset it really
reinforced this puzzle mindset which is
all about seeing the world as puzzles
don't get furious get curious
flexible thinking all that
but more specifically
i do think
every morning i have some rituals where
i i spend 15 minutes brainstorming ideas
and 99 of them suck
but i just feel that the mental
gymnastic the sort of the aerobic
workout of your brain
is very helpful
in solving real puzzles and and life
puzzles and coming up with new ideas but
in addition to that now i am addicted to
several puzzles
if you're gonna have an addiction i
think it's a good one so i i do the
spelling bee in the new york times
wordle which was such a huge phenomenon
a friend of mine described it as the ted
lasso of puzzles because it's very
nicely you know you're probably going to
get it so uh it's not too sadistic and
of course the new york times crossword
puzzle so
i will continue to do that and and i
will also i loved
all of the
dozens of subcultures of people i met so
i do hope to keep in touch with them
because they are such
curious and and bizarre and interesting
thinkers and such great characters
is there any subculture that you know if
the
if the task or the question was
okay twice a month for the next year you
need to have dinner with someone from
this subculture
like a long dinner not a show
could be beers could be something else
but just like i'm wondering which
subculture you're like you know i could
be like an honorary
or dishonorable inductee for a short
period of time depending on how things
go
where do you think you would lean
there are so many that i find
fascinating but one i do love the code
breakers the cryptographers
and i'm terrible at codes and they range
from professional cryptographers to
you know janitors to
writers to artists but they are all
obsessed with breaking codes the kryptos
one i mentioned but also there's
something called the zodiac killer and
his letters so those are still in there
they're like
in a few dozen codes that still have
never been solved but they obsess over
them one of the ones i featured in my
book was this amazing woman named alanka
dunnon who she consulted on codes for
the cia and the fbi
after 9 11 and she is so obsessed with
kryptos that she moved
to dc to be closer to kryptos
wow talking to them you realize how much
secret codes i won't say in fact though
just
affect every part of our lives you know
cryptocurrency and
your bank account and uh your passwords
and
these secret code and and you know
military so secret codes may be a puzzle
but they are a crucial puzzle
for humanity and in fact one of the
historical things i mentioned in the
book
is that there was um
a puzzle in 1942 in the telegraph
newspaper
and it was a crossword puzzle and it
said at the bottom if you solve this in
12 minutes or less
call this number and that number turned
out to be the the british secret service
the the spy agency and
and it was a recruitment tool for the
people who cracked the enigma code the
nazi enigma code so you could say the
crossover puzzle saved the world
and for people interested i just want to
lay out the spelling so kryptos is
k-r-y-p-t-o-s
sculptured by the american artist jim
sanborn located on the grounds of the
central intelligence agency in langley
virginia
and there's a whole wikipedia entry
but certainly the first hand experience
of having having spent time there
as you did
i think is is working into do you find
not to in any way imply that the woman
you just mentioned
false pray to this but that
people interested in cryptography have a
high risk of
i want to say psychosis but
seeing it seeing signal where there is
noise right so ending up succumbing to
all sorts of conspiracy theories or god
knows what i mean there are a million
pitfalls
yeah kind of in the gray zone
total i mean that is i love that
question because that i do have i talk
about the dark side of puzzle i think
they're mostly a force for good
but
if you don't have that flexibility of
mind and you get obsessed with puzzles
and you fall in love with your
particular hypothesis there's a word for
it it's as not psychosis it's apophenia
apophenia is one of my favorite words i
learned and it is when you see signal in
the noise i mean the classic is you see
jesus jesus's face on a piece of french
toast
and yes it is a big danger i mean you
look at these online groups for cryptos
and their people like no it's got to be
in morse code it's got to be
the illuminati yes there's definitely i
mean q and on is basically a puzzle gone
wrong it's people who have figured out a
solution that they think is right and no
amount of counter evidence will allow
them to change their mind so yeah you
got and i also have a section in the
book about
this famous book from in 1980 81 in
england where it was a picture book with
clues to a hidden treasure a golden
rabbit hidden somewhere in england and
it caused a mania like people were
digging up yards and trespassing looking
for this
for this gold finally someone found it
but what was crazy is that even after
someone found it there were dozens
hundreds of people who were like no no
my theory is right i they refused to
abandon their theory even after it was
uh it was found and that to me is a very
dangerous look at the the dark side of
human nature
wow apophenia learning all sorts of
things
so
let's take a revisit of this subtitle so
one man's quest to solve the most
baffling puzzles ever from crosswords to
jigsaws to the meaning of life so i'm
going to give you
there's a fork in the road that we can
take here
and we can we can go to meaning of life
and you can expand on why that's in the
subtitle
or
or
we could go
to
the hardest corn maze in the world
well let's if you have time maybe i'll
just do quickly the corn maze i have
time i feel like if you do the meaning
of life that's kind of
like where do you go from there right
right hard to segue from that to the
corn maze exactly but yes the i have a
section on mazes which was were
fascinating and
and i i found the hardest corn maze in
the world is in vermont and it is so
hard
talk about sadism the guy who created it
just
revels in the amount of pain and misery
he got you know he talks joyously about
couples getting into massive fights
people weeping you know hundreds of
people just breaking out in tears of
frustration a father who abandoned his
family and drove off because he was so
busy
so it is incredibly hard there are
emergency exits because it's so hard
people get freaked out
and i i did it it took about four and a
half hours and um and uh and a bunch of
hints
but i loved interviewing him because one
of the things hold on a bunch of hints
do you have an earpiece and he's like go
right i can see you from the drone go
left
what uh does is he stands on a platform
in the middle of the maze like a god and
you can go up to him and plead your case
you know i'm so frustrated
can you help me oh my god that's
incredible
but i asked him you know standing on
that platform what have you learned from
observing human nature and he said
that one the theme that we've talked
about is
you know the ones who are never going to
make it out are the ones who have no
flexibility of mind who just
go down the scene they're like this is
the way i swear and they'll hit a wall
they'll go back they'll do it again
they'll keep it he does say that teenage
boys are particularly prone to this so i
have teenage boys i'm trying to say you
know flexibility you got to be flexible
uh because i guess the testosterone
kicks in and it's like i'm right go
testosterone yeah so he was great and i
am a big fan of mazes another genre that
i wasn't particularly
obsessed with before but i do see the
beauty of them now
mazes
yeah mazes
vermont unexpectedly has come up quite a
bit i mean you mentioned the sort of
bill gates
bugatti of jigsaw puzzles
from the chief tormentor which i think
you mentioned were made in vermont
you've got the most difficult corn maze
in the world in vermont it makes me
think of these unlikely epicenters or
places that are famous for things you
wouldn't expect right like gil gilroy
california is the garlic capital of the
world right you would never guess that
unless you happen to be driving by it as
i as i had many times when i lived in
california are there hotbeds of puzzle
creation
is that just vermont i mean these are
not as unexpected these are not gilroy
but japan makes amazing
puzzles russia is known for making me
and and one of the chapters is about
chess puzzles which are different from
chess games and i interviewed i played
with gary kasparov
who is a big fan of chess puzzle
although he himself is not the greatest
chess puzzler because it's a different
a different skill than regular chess and
just very quickly a chess puzzle is when
you have a certain arrangement of pieces
on the board like a king and and a rook
and
and a queen and you have to
mate checkmate the other side in a
certain number of moves so it's it's a
constrained puzzle as opposed to an
unconstrained game and these people
there's it's a different skill set there
these people who are like the gary
kasparovs of of chess puzzles and i love
talking to him because you've had him on
the show right i imagine i haven't i
have i you know the only time i've ever
met uh well i didn't really meet him
gary kasparov quick side note
is
when i was presenting it ted however
many years ago and it was my first time
you know on this big stage this big
event i was very nervous and i was told
by the organizers
well
before you go up when you're like three
or four out you can go into the zen pod
or they had some word for this place it
was supposed to be very calming had
all of this beautiful imagery and it was
supposed to be this very zen
sedating
place where you could prepare for what
would otherwise be very very stressful
and i remember walking out because i was
sweating already to whatever this zen
pod was and
the people on deck before me were gary
kasparov and like
two other super geniuses and they were
pacing like they're on death row about
to go to execution and i was like this
is not gonna help my nerves and so i
turned around and i left that is my one
and only exposure to to garry kasparov
that is funny yeah that would not be
good for your nerves and and i will tell
you i mean he was very gracious to come
to my apartment and and allow me to
interview him i will say he's not like
the softest and cuddliest guy
which is probably good you know he saw
this vladimir putin thing coming but he
when he came i had set up my chest set
so that we wouldn't waste any time and
he looked at it and he said that is a
very cheap chess set i see and i was
like yeah
that was like a plastic thing i bought
on amazon and i was like oh
and he said no don't worry i grew up in
the soviet union i'm used to cheap
plastic
chestnuts so he forgave me but he was
not impressed
but he was fascinated because one of the
keys he says to chess puzzles is again
the counter-intuitive and looking at the
long view the long view which he's good
at in in life as well that
the best puzzles make you do things
that are short-term crazy like sacrifice
your queen a lot of them are about
sacrificing your queen but in the in the
long run they will they will pay off so
that's i like that as a life lesson just
look at the long view
yeah i imagine i mean i know very little
about chess but that perhaps the reason
these chess puzzles
are not comparable to chess games is
that they are
presenting the pieces and configurations
that would
almost never occur in a in a natural
game right and i do know some very good
chess players but but they become
very good at
chunking the board into sections where
they might recognize
a particular
sequence of moves that they
have
already recorded to memory from studying
historic games or having played a
thousand
matches
in a certain way
but when you then get to
a puzzle perhaps it's almost nonsensical
right there isn't any
historical record to kind of play off of
to figure out what the next best move is
that's exactly it i mean that is some of
the most famous puzzles are just crazy
there's a genre called grotesques which
sounds uh very intense grotesque puzzles
uh chess puzzles and it'll be 16 black
pieces and only two white pieces
but white can win and you have to figure
out how can white win so it's a real
like david versus goliath thing but yeah
they look crazy you know they're 16
black pieces huddled in the corner never
would happen in a real game
all right meaning of life i think we've
i think we've pushed it as long as we
can all right well i first of all put it
in there just because i wanted to show
puzzles are not trivial like you know
waste time frivolous that uh so there's
a little of that
so i may not have actually solved the
meaning of life
by the end
but i will say and i hope it doesn't
come off as pat because i truly believe
it part of the meaning of life is the
search for the meaning of life for sure
because curiosity as we've said over and
over
is to me one of the greatest gifts
it's a key to a joyous life it's a key
to resolving conflicts it's a key
to
to business family
everything so to me like never giving up
on the search for the meaning of life is
a big part of the meaning of life
less furious more curious so that came
originally or your source was parenting
advice
yeah i was watching
they had a webinar deep in the middle of
the pandemic where it was as child
psychologists and that you know ways to
survive the pandemic with your kids
because you know it was just horrible so
i was like maybe there's something and
and that was the phrase he used and he
meant it in parenting terms so like when
your two-year-old is throwing a tantrum
don't get furious
you know get curious why is is the kid
throwing a tantrum what can we do to
prevent it in the future what will work
so instead of just getting angry and
giving up
look at it from with a sense and and i
think that's very good for your own
mental health otherwise you know when i
read the newspaper or i don't read the
newspaper when i read media online
parade when you're reading parade
my favorite column in parade
i mean i do read the paper just not like
folded paper but uh when i'm doing that
if i don't look at it like a puzzle i i
get so angry and
and it's just not good for my health
so yeah look at it more like there are
different ways to put it some people say
the engineer mindset versus the
the lawyer mindset i i like adam grant
as he calls it the um
be a uh a scientist the scientist
worldview instead of the prosecutor or
the preacher
or the he had one other p he was very
good with the alliteration so yeah look
look at the world that way
but they're all the same theme
pescetarian maybe
could be pessimistic
exactly those pescetarians are very
narrow-minded
well aj what's
we've covered a fair bit
but i'm
i'd still love to hear you just
reiterate for people
what you hope
they gain
not just from the book certainly the
book i mean i hope people check them out
i've never been disappointed by a book
of yours i think you're an excellent
an excellent writer but also an
excellent entertainer and the
combination of those two i think
often results in you being an
outstanding teacher because you take
what can otherwise be very difficult to
absorb or difficult to understand and
you you provide a wrapper that makes it
really easy to digest and i've always
admired that
and that goes
back to some of your earliest work
certainly the year of living biblically
i thought was was outstanding
what do you hope people will get from
from from this and puzzles if there are
any stones we haven't
turned over yet yeah well
tons i mean
just to reiterate some of what we've
covered i i mean it's got tons of
puzzles in it so i hope that they will
do those and find the joy of puzzles
it's got the contest which i hope you'll
enjoy even if you don't win it's got my
adventures
but it's also got this way of
hopefully looking at the world which
will make your life better make you
happier more effective more productive
both in the macro sense of looking at
the world as a puzzle and in the more
micro sense of here are 10 strategies
for solving puzzles and we went over
three or four of them but there are
plenty more in the book and yeah i hope
that people
i think it's funny because i didn't plan
this i feel very lucky but
you know we are in a puzzle boom right
now and uh people are obsessed with
wordle and jigsaws and
so i hope that that as as covet
hopefully ends that that doesn't die
that people will continue this
love of puzzles because i really do
think that they make the world a better
place and and maybe if i can i'm gonna
you know what oh this is good i'm gonna
make you a little
a little gift box of puzzles that are
going to blow your mind and and get you
sucked back into the puzzle cult oh i
would love that the the gateway drug box
of puzzles by aj jacobs yes
i would love that i would love that
thank you so much and and i also
want to give voices something that i've
been thinking throughout this entire
conversation and that is
if you and you pointed this out already
when i said that i dropped puzzles i
haven't dropped puzzles it's just that
my narrow definition of puzzles
needs to be expanded right and if we
think of puzzles in a sense as games
with certain rules certain constraints
certain desired outcomes
then we're all playing games
if you think about you know outs outside
of the lowest rungs of maslow's
hierarchy of needs i mean what we're
opting into we are playing games and i
guess the
the first order of business is to try to
identify which games we're playing
and try to make sure we're playing the
right games because the social
conventions around us can be enabling or
disabling and
i would
expect that the way you present subject
matter and the way you tell stories will
help people to realize that the water
they swim in is already full of puzzles
and that by as you said sort of working
on the micro puzzles
you can develop
capacities that then translate to the
the macro puzzles
you just reminded me you you have been
doing puzzles i mean
in your first book when you talked about
the the martial arts competition you won
that was a puzzle that was like you used
an innovative technique and then tango
also a puzzle so yeah you are a puzzler
whether you know it or not
i suppose that's true for a lot of
people
listening aj is there anything else that
you would like to
mention any requests you'd like to make
public complaints you'd like to lodge
anything at all that you would like to
add before we bring this this
conversation to to close i will say i
mean i hope you buy my book or at least
take it out library or enjoy it or talk
about it but um i i have not settled on
my next book and and i have found that
readers
or just listeners have sometimes
wonderful ideas
sometimes not but uh sometimes
interesting ideas so if you feel like
getting in touch with me through my um
my website or twitter i would love to
hear from you
about what you think i should embark on
next
wonderful people can find you at
ajacobs.com aj jacobs on twitter
what can people find at the
puzzlerbook.com what will people find on
this website that is where you enter the
code for the contest that will open up
to about 20 wild puzzles that i did not
design these greg poliska and these
great designers made them so if you want
to enter the contest it's
thepuzzlerbook.com and there are all
these disclaimers about you have to be
18 and live in the united states etc etc
so that's on there but you can also
there are a bunch of puzzles on there as
well so even if you don't enter the
contest it might be worth checking out
a little something for everybody and
we'll link to all of the social link to
all the websites in the show notes at
tim.blog podcast as per usual
and i'm very happy that you made it both
into the saturday and tuesday editions
of the new york times crossfit puzzle
and getting a twofer that that seems you
know unless you're
justin bieber i i think i i mean i have
to imagine that's quite an unusual honor
right and i can just get a double header
i don't deserve it but i am happy to
take it well who deserves anything i
mean i think you you were able to you
managed to appear twice
so one could one could argue the results
justify in this case the means
and uh so nice to see you again aj
thanks for taking the time so fun what a
what a blast thank you tim
and
for everybody listening
as always and as i already mentioned
we'll have links to all the resources
in the show notes at tim.log slash
podcast and certainly check out aj's new
book the puzzler subtitle one man's
quest to solve the most baffling puzzles
ever from crosswords to jigsaws to the
meaning of life
and until next time be a little kinder
than is necessary take care of
yourselves and thanks for tuning in
you